so because your gut is constantly
communicating with your brain again if
your gut is not happy things are
communicating differently but also you
could just not be producing enough
serotonin for various different reasons
or your gut might not be sending the
right signals up to your brain so you
might have if we looked at your
microbiome and it's certainly not
necessary to do that we can do this in
clinic without testing if we looked at
your microbiome we might find that
you've just not got enough of these
bacteria that are doing this particular
important job with brain connection
stuff
um so what we would suggest then is to
really optimize the gut and you know
what happens Ali as you know is when
people are busy and they're working too
hard and they're doing a side hustle and
everything else is high pressure or
they've got a family and everything else
people tend to make their diet quite
small in not necessarily in terms of
volume but the types of foods that
they're eating so they might end up
eating the same types of foods on repeat
what I see is people there's kind of two
camps here the people who do like the
meal prep stuff and they eat the same
Foods five days a week and they think
they're being super healthy eating sweet
potato and broccoli every day or you
have the people who are just living meal
to meal prep you know Etsy wherever
they're going every day the same sort of
of things but just various different
places and nothing's particularly
planned or thought through and
inevitably both of those ways of eating
have an impact on your gut health
whether you feel it in your gut or not
so that way of eating limits the types
of fibers that you'll get bacteria being
fed and the most important thing for
your gut health is that you're eating 30
different plants a week so trying to eat
loads of variety of different types of
plants that includes fruit and
vegetables so nuts and whole grains
different types of grains we're super
fixated in this country on like oats and
wheat but actually there's so many
different types of grains that our gut
really benefits from
so when you're busy and you're
struggling and you're eating meal to
meal or you're eating the same Foods on
repeat what happens is you've got Health
you've got sort of function might not
change but your gut health is inevitably
not optimized and that's when you can
have these problems with lack of
concentration Focus energy getting bugs
all the time that kind of stuff and
really interestingly your gut bacteria
communicate with your hypothalamus so
that bit of your brain that controls
things like cortisol production so
really early in your life your gut
bacteria dictate where your sort of HPA
axis is set so how much cholesterol you
release in under given circumstances and
we all need some cortisol right but we
don't want loads and loads of cortisol
because we've got loads of anxiety and
stress all the time we can really
struggle to concentrate and to focus so
we can use our gut bacteria to try and
reduce that and make things a little bit
better in that department we can use
them and harness their powers to get
more serotonin which helps us with
better sleep and concentration and focus
and all those important things those
happy hormones and we can also just try
and calm down those messages from our
gut to our brain which are distracting
our brain all the time and your gut
bacteria are going to be saying we need
more plants and you're going to be not
reading that properly and giving them
more Sushi and that's not quite what
they want wow so
it sounds like you're saying please
correct me if this is an
oversimplification that changing up what
you eat can have a massive impact on
your Focus productivity performance
happiness absolutely because all of
those things are linked gut brain
everything yeah fundamentally I mean and
proven in amazing research in science
yeah what kind of research has been done
on this I guess I'm I'm thinking healthy
people rather than people with official
gut problems yeah so uh the amazing work
of John cryen is a really good place to
to start looking at this stuff if people
are interested and he's written an
amazing book called The psychobiotic
Revolution so psychobiotics are these
gut bacteria that communicate with our
brain so they're the ones that we're
particularly interested in when we
develop the height smart probiotic for
example so work that's been done in that
area to start within rodent models they
used a model of an autistic mouse and a
model of a non-autistic mouse or
sociable Mouse and they took the
microbiome so they took a sample and and
gave the microbiome of the autistic
Mouse to the sociable Mouse and the
sociable Mouse starts to show autistic
traits okay and when they swap them over
the autistic Mouse starts to become a
sociable Mouse just because it's got
microbiomass changed yeah so that was
the early work that they did trying to
understand how much our gut microbiome
is impacted impacting our mental health
our mental performance how our brain is
working so similar studies to that have
then been replicated in humans in other
places and to be clear that autistic
Spectrum Disorder stuff in humans is so
complex and we can't replicate that
exactly in humans as yet but there's
certainly something going on there which
is what we generally learn from rodent
studies we've also got some great data
showing things like increase in
production of Serotonin when we use
particular probiotic species there's
great data showing that using particular
probiotic species within treatment diets
and things like that so within treatment
within studies in controlled studies
improves anxiety depression all of these
kinds of symptoms and wider nutrients
within this world if we think about
things like Omega-3s and B vitamins
they've been used in place of anxiety
and depression medications ssris that
kind of stuff and they work as
effectively in some people some of the
time in study so we can use all of these
things and a similar work has been done
with the two straight one two of the
strains we use in the smart probiotic
in terms of seeing whether they work as
effectively as common anti-depression
anti-anxiety medications and they do so
much so that there's Health claims on
them in Canada that people can say these
are definitely shown to improve anxiety
and depression
so there's great data it's a young field
of research but it's super exciting and
it's very solid research just showing
that the magic that we can harness from
our gut hey friends thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this clip
then click here for the full unedited
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day bye